I've learned so much from defeats you
know my students defeats after I beat
coiler Gracie in 2003 that was in the
middle of a tournament so it wasn't like
a like a super fight or anything that he
would he was the second round of a
16-man tournament so to win a 60 man
term you have to win four matches and
won the first one and then I ran into
hor the Gracie on my second match beat
him and in the third match
I got [ __ ] smoked by Leo Vieira who's
a multiple time national or world
champion and you weren't even a black
belt that that now was a brown belt
right so I approached I approached going
to Brazil and doing that tournament like
I had zero to lose I didn't expect I
expected to get stomped and it was right
in the middle of me working on the man
show and being super depressed I was
super depressed that from day one
the producers everybody there would just
they didn't think you had it dicks they
were they didn't want to hire me Joe
made them hire me good cuz Joe Joe said
Joe's right in the middle of Fear Factor
he's a huge star and then he gets asked
to do the show and the only reason he
considered it cuz me and him were
already right and sketched we already
had sketches right so after I shocked
the world and it was the biggest upset
in jiu-jitsu history 20 minutes later I
get my house tour and did you feel I
felt like okay that just if it was like
winning the Super Bowl and then them
coming out going you got to play another
Super Bowl and then getting killed in
that Super Bowl would you still feel
happy it'd be like I don't know like I
was doing I was like a little depressed
man do you realize that that's how life
is it's like you can only really get on
such a high if your ego gets too high I
feel like anyway for me every time
there's gonna be something right after
yes that's gonna level you out yeah when
shit's going great I feel I'm like damn
everything is so good something's go
someone's gonna [ __ ] oh I started taking
I always feel holsters I start making
sure everybody's ok I'm like somebody's
gonna [ __ ] Rock yeah I feel that way
so what I learned from that match was I
approached that match with the worse
mentality ever I I lost before the match
because before that tournament I'm even
though beating one of the Gracie was
huge I thought at that time the hardest
guy was gonna be Leo Viera because the
the championship before that he was up a
weight class and he went against my
master Jean Jacques Machado
and even though my master Jean Jean
Jacques Machado beat him in higher
weight class my master didn't tap him
and he [ __ ] me up at will he taps me at
will so I thought damn that kind of must
be really good if he survived he still
lost but he survived and then by the
time the next championship rolled around
a BCC he decided to lose weight and come
down my weight class I'm like oh no this
[ __ ] is gonna be in my weight
class
holy [ __ ] so I was really worried about
that guy yeah I wasn't worried as much
about how the Gracie who was the champ
at my weight division the last three
championships and no one's ever scored a
point against him but because he didn't
look menacing he looked kind of lanky he
didn't look yoked he I felt like [ __ ] I
think I could beat him right I felt a
little hotter this year this year I felt
like I could beat him just because he
was skinny yeah but Leo Vieira he's like
it's super efficient an acrobat do
backflips like it's nothing
I was worried don't come in his mouth
Wow so after I upset Hoyle ER already
right away I knew who was next and I was
thinking this it's like winning a
million dollars but knowing that you got
to give it all back you know like [ __ ]
how do you feel you want to know
backstage we're going dude you [ __ ]
up you shocked the world I was like yeah
I did didn't I
but I'm thinking about my next match
ready go on what do you how you feeling
like ain't over yet and some guys about
to ruin my party
he's about to [ __ ] my Superbowl
champagne pop collaboration oh that's
all I'm thinking he I wasn't I wasn't
that happy cuz I knew it was all coming
to an end and so so I approached that
match thinking that he was gonna [ __ ] me
out I was like already like there's he's
gonna [ __ ] up my whole party like
lightning can strike and when I walked
on the match to face him he was really
worried about me he's in a yoga he's in
a yoga stance or am I
in yoga position with this his thumbs
together like that his eyes closed and
he's he's doing all these breathing
exercises like on the side of the
mountain here I'm walking out already
thinking that I'm gonna get killed and
his coach is yelling like you know she
was [ __ ] in his ear in Portuguese I'm
sure it was probably like he's just a
human you could beat him you're better
than him you know yeah you got to get
yourself confident like coach and I'm
thinking that is so unnecessary
everything you guys are doing you can't
[ __ ] me up that's the guy that's the
mentality ahead I already lost ya and
halfway through that match he was
[ __ ] me a pass in my guard and just
all these points and tap and I'm just
like listless and then halfway through
that match I snapped out of it and I
thought wait a minute my doing I gotta
go after this guy what am i doing like
I'm in a fog over here so it was too
late though I snapped out of it I
wouldn't even if I were to had a winning
attitude he would have still beat me but
not as bad I think so I learned from
that that how important having
confidence is in doing anything whether
it's jiu-jitsu or music and you got to
have confidence yeah otherwise you know
you know not confidence that you're
gonna win a hundred percent but
confidence that you can win and that you
know what you're doing and win yeah you
can't lose too but you got to know that
you can win too if if you know things go
your way and with a little luck and you
know yeah I used to be so bad at
basketball but when I would get in the
games I would be so nervous that I would
completely that would overshadow any of
my skill set or anything it felt like my
hands didn't belong to me anymore
it just felt bizarre yeah and it was it
had nothing to do with my physical
ability it was all wrapped in confidence
in confidence and stand-ups like that if
you don't have confidence you can
onstage you're gonna eat [ __ ] yeah you
gotta [ __ ] you better fake that
confidence you better get up there and
do it yeah it feels a lot more yeah and
that's one thing that's that's changed
for me in the past year even two years
is just I feel when I get on stage now
like oh I'm excited about putting on
this show for these people whether then
can I put on this show for these people
yeah you know it's not can I anymore
it's I'm excited to have fun yeah I'm
gonna have fun and they're gonna have
fun yeah and this is gonna be a blast
and and I don't even feel like it's
almost less ego now
it used to be like I had this chip on my
shoulder sometimes like i'ma show these
[ __ ] you know this Eminem like
[ __ ] all these white people we've know
I'm white I would say like [ __ ] like
that
and now we just wanna hammer the jokes
into him so hard but it came from a
place a little bit of edge you know yeah
whereas now it comes from a place like I
want them to have fun you know and I
know that that if I take care of myself
and show up and be okay and ride this
confidence and I know it's gonna work
for both of us you know it's definitely
a little bit different what's up guys
sitting here with this marijuana plant I
think also could be just a regular plant
it could be poison ivy brought about to
smoke myself in some itchy itchy just
watch another clip since you're already
here you know I'm saying